All right, everyone. I'm Bav Offs. This
is Dexter.
>> Hi.
>> I work on Baml on I make programming
language, Dexter.
>> Uh I'm Dex. I'm the founder of Human
Layer and I make tools to make agentic
coding easier and better. And this is
the AI at Work Show where we give you
about an hour a week of practical coding
tips for advanced usage and to improve
your use of AI.
>> Exactly.
Um and then our whole goal here is
always um
Sorry, one second.
Uh
I apologize for that. Uh I'm working
from home today cuz the internet at our
office is dead.
Uh so sadly, I was stuck here and our
cleaners were around. So I was like, let
me go tell them not to do the top floor.
Um but
one of the things that Dexter and I
always talk about is context
engineering. We talk about how to go and
build these systems.
And I think a lot of people forget that
all these AI applications that we are
all building,
whether we're the user or the engineer
building them,
every single one of us has to think
about context engineering along that
loop.
You have to as a user of an application,
you have to be like, how can I context
engineer Claude the best to make it
generate the code I want? As a builder
of Claude uh Claude code, I need to go
ahead and think about how can I make it
so that the agent will do what the user
wants more of the time. And that it's
that symbiosis of both systems
that it actually makes a really
beautiful experience that makes us be
like, wow, and blows our minds away and
says these AI agents are actually really
good.
And well, normally a lot of our past
episodes have been talking about how to
be actually write some of these agents.
Today, I think there's some real magic
in really thinking about how we're going
to go ahead and almost
be the users.
And think about how can we as users our
best efforts
to go and make these agents work the way
that make them work the way that we
really want them to work.
And one really interesting insight that
I have personally learned
uh working with Dex on these kind of
things and I've been learning from him a
lot actually on these topics.
>> Sorry.
>> Um
comes down to the fact of like
I actually become a better agent builder
by becoming a better agent user.
Cuz it helps me think about like what
are the UX patterns that I wish existed
in these apps. What are the mistakes
that the agent was making and how do I
actually want to interface with them?
For example, last week's episode was
about how to build agents that you can
interrupt.
Why does it Why does that matter? Well,
the most frustrating thing is when I'm
in ChatGPT and I tell it to do something
and it starts spitting out text and
halfway through I'm like, "No, no, no,
go in that direction." What I have to do
there is I have to hit cancel, edit my
previous message, and then press enter.
I wish I could just send a message.
And there's small things like that that
help us think about the design patterns
that we need to do when we build these
agents.
And so today we're going to do something
really exciting
which is
be users of Claude Code.
Dex, you want to
take it away?
>> I would love to, yeah. Um
so yeah, I think um just kind of
hammering that down a little bit. Like
one of the things we say a lot in
context engineering
is um you know, LLMs are stateless
functions, right? So you have your LLM
like the LLM outputs some kind of tokens
and that's like, you know,
you have your answer
and this answer has a spectrum of
quality from like, you know,
it's slop
to hey, that's really, really good.
Um and the only thing that kind of
affects the quality of this answer, if
you're using a fixed LLM and kind of
fixed parameters, is the quality of the
tokens you put in.
And the tokens you put in is essentially
going to be a context window, right? You
could think people talk about prompt
engineering and a prompt, but at the end
of the day, you're going to have a bunch
of different components of what you put
in. You're going to have your system
message.
You're going to have some, you know,
maybe if you did some rag or injected
stuff, um you may like pull some data
from somewhere else.
You're going to have actually If you're
building an AI application, right? Then
you may pull in the user message, um
and then you may put in some like, you
know, instructions.
And then you may also put in some like
memories, right? There's There's all
kinds of stuff you could put in this
context window, and you can shuffle
We've done a lot of episodes on like
shuffling the order of these things and
figuring out how to make them more
concise and more optimized for the LLM.
And so that's If you're writing the code
and you're just structuring everything
around this LLM call, then um
you have a lot of um
like levers you can pull to improve the
performance of this answer that your
system gets or that your user gets.
Um but today we're going to talk And And
And 2 weeks ago we talked about like
just If you are not the agent builder
and you're just the agent user, and the
only thing you control is the user
message, why it's so important to
understand um actually We'll change this
to tools cuz that's more relevant. Um
why it's so important to understand the
other parts of the prompt and where your
message gets injected, because at the
end of the day, you're just one step
removed, but you're still doing context
engineering. You just have less control.
The agent builder owns these parts, and
you only own your user message.
Does that make sense?
>> Exactly. And like one important thing to
think about as an agent builder here is
while we all aspire to almost hide all
these parts purely from our users and
hope that they're purely implementation
details,
in practice,
you actually make it harder for the
users of your app to go do something
better when you make it totally
abstracted. It's important
I would say it's almost your obligation
as an agent builder to at least have
some provide some insight to your users
about how things work.
It's kind of like if you ever use like
any sort of like um
like social media, there's some feedback
loop that you get from like Twitter or
LinkedIn about like what content is
doing well and you're able to navigate
that yourself. Even if you don't know
exactly what's going on, there's some
feedback loop that's available to you
that you can iterate. Some people become
amazing content creators because they
learn how to grasp that signal way
better than other people do.
Same thing here.
But if you're building a tool and you
make it too hard for most users to
understand how to min-max your tool,
they're just not going to use it because
it'll it'll end up more on the slop side
than the really good side.
>> Yeah, and this is expected from there,
right? Like some users, sometimes you
want to make an AI for users that are
not very sophisticated and don't
understand the tool calls or just JSON
objects that get injected in with a
schema and things like that. And then in
that case it's like may if you're
building like an AI for uh people to
get, you know,
uh
you know, let's say medical advice an AI
veterinarian that's going to help people
like figure out what's going on with
their pets, it's like unlikely those
people are very thoughtful context
engineers. Some of them maybe, but then
when you're building a coding agent
that's going to be used by really
technical people, then this becomes a
lot more important.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Um two quick like kind of throwbacks. Um
I think it's here. Yeah, so we did this
episode about um Claude code and and
using like kind of like
context engineering and applying it to
how you use coding agents.
Um we're not actually going to talk much
about that today, although some of the
same concepts are going to be in there.
I think we get asked about a lot and a
thing that I've been doing a lot and
really enjoying that I thought I would
share some some experiences on is how to
use Claude code to do things that are
not writing code.
Um because it's actually just a very
good general purpose agent and the fact
that it can write code is really
interesting because instead of instead
of having to find MCP tools for
everything, Claude can kind of just
write its own scripts. So, I'm going to
walk through a couple concepts that I
think are really important to understand
here and then we'll demo I have a demo
set of code in the repo about um
kind of how we use this. And Andrew,
yes, the Claude code system prompt is
all about code, but it still works
pretty well for other things as well.
Oops.
Um
so this is um I've set up
a little
>> Brian uh
while you pull that up, Tess. Brian,
that's a question. Isn't there a
spectrum of like novice users to power
users? There completely is, but that's
kind of why it's important for you as an
agent builder to think really carefully
about what that spectrum is for your
users and where they fall on. If your
users fall more towards the novice side,
like they're not going to go do it, it's
not just about exposing user messages,
it's actually about building really
interesting UI paradigms so that a thing
that is typically viewed as a user
message
is actually going to be act have like
some additional metadata. For example,
let's say you're building a rag system
that's going to go at answer questions
about it.
Um can I draw on your screen, Tess?
>> Go for it. Um oh, let me share the link
so you can actually draw on the
whiteboard itself.
>> That would actually be much better.
Um
and then we'll go back to this really
fast. And then um uh
Amo, yes, all the recordings are shared.
If you've signed up on um
if you signed up on the Luma link, you
will get
an email automatically at the end of
either tomorrow or uh by the end of this
week at the latest.
>> And they're also all here in the repo.
If you go to the AI that works repo,
there is an index of all of the past
episodes. So, if you want to go binge
them, um
please go go do that and have fun.
>> So, just to be really concrete, really
first on this like one way to build a
search box is to just say search box and
now I'll magically do rag under the
hood. Another way to build a search box
is just to say like here's a rag I'm
pulling from under the hood and I will
actually like what cursor does and you
can use the at symbol to refer to other
documents.
And whether it's a word doc or something
else or Google Docs doesn't really
matter, but it allows the user to have
some UX that basically intervenes into
the context building without even
feeling like it's intervening into the
context when
context um
building. And you can do this with
tools, you can do this with rags, you
can do this with almost anything.
But and it doesn't even have to be pure
green. It could be half user, half
>> blend, right?
>> Exactly. You can have a blend.
But this is going to where you can think
about how you like how how easy and hard
something feels is purely based on the
amount of developer experience that you
are willing to
impose on your end users based on the
amount of engineering work that you're
willing to do. If you're willing to do
more engineering work, you can basically
give your users full control of
everything. If you're really good at UX,
it won't even feel bad.
If you're really bad at UX, you'll
basically make them reinvent context
engineering from scratch and then you
better hope your users are extremely
extremely technical.
>> Yeah, I love it.
Um great. So um one thing that we've
been doing is essentially we create a
uh
we've created a a Git repo that we use
to do all of our non-technical things.
And so I'll walk through kind of one
example, which is a CRM. Um we don't use
a CRM anymore. Um Claude Code runs our
CRM.
And while you could have Claude Code
have an MCP tool that talks to
Salesforce or Linear or Airtable or
whatever you're using for your CRM,
we've actually just found this works
really well with Markdown documents. And
so um I have um I'll push all this code.
I haven't pushed it yet. Um but we have
kind of a core structure of a fictional
company that is a on-demand burrito
delivery platform. Um, I also have a
couple real examples from our internal
stuff that I will not be sharing. Uh,
but I will show them to you here. Um, so
I've cleaned this up a little bit. But
this is uh, let's just delete this
folder just in case there's still stuff
in it.
Um, this is like um, reveals another
company in our YC batch. They do really
cool stuff. Um, but you'll see a couple
things here is like this is a markdown
document that explains the people we're
talking to and what's happened so far.
Um, we also have contacts for all of
these people.
Um,
and then we have events. So like this is
an event of And so like these are all
things that you could imagine being
sequel objects in a database. But what's
been working really well is like if you
keep them as markdown then there's no
tool calls required other than just
reading and writing files.
And what you have is you start to build
out basically rather than like a
relationship graph that we would use
with a sequel database, we're kind of
faking it with building a knowledge
graph as markdown files that kind of
just point to each other. And it's a lot
more freeform and it's a lot more
structureless.
Um, but that gives you a lot of
flexibility in terms of And like Claude
can rewrite any of this stuff. You can
fire off about If you decide you don't
like the structure, you can do something
else. But it's basically the combination
of like front matter for deterministic
things.
Um, so you could feed this part to code
and it's metadata about the document and
then Claude can read the document and
the front matter, but like read the
document and understand how it's going.
>> And I want to I want to call out a
couple things really fast. The reason
that this works now and it didn't used
to work before is cuz the models are
getting better.
So and this is just an emergent
capability that we'll all discover over
time
of exactly what's going on. But if you
go ahead and assume that that model can
never do something, you won't be able to
push it to the limit of what it's
actually able to do.
>> Yeah. And this isn't perfect yet. And
it's it's not just the models, too. I
would say it's also the agents
themselves.
>> Yes.
>> Um and so here's like a here's our
engagement history, right? So and I'll
show you how this data gets in, but it's
like it's not just the models
themselves. It's like the agent harness,
right? Claude code is not just Claude's
a great model and it's really, really
well trained and tuned for doing this
kind of work, but it's also that the
harness around it is really, really
tailored to modifying files in a repo.
Um
and so oh, we got a lot of notes in the
chat. Uh Tyler, the way you So, this is
a great question. So, it's like do would
this scale over thousands of contacts?
Um and so the way that we scale this
across thousands of contacts is
basically by doing deterministic
contacts packing, basically. And so what
what we have in here is we have a
makefile
that essentially um
is ways to kind of deterministically
build up your context. And so rather
than having the agent go This is one's
very specific to like, "Hey, let's just
show the first 100 lines of of a couple
different files."
Oh god.
Uh sorry, I was doing some last minute
prep here. So, uh excuse my uh insane
cursor stuff.
Um and I know I said I don't really use
editors anymore, but I do use cursor
when I'm in a hurry and I procrastinated
on the episode prep.
Um
So, here's the one that we had for human
layer, basically, which is, you know,
um our company, everything we have, our
read me, our bi-weekly meeting notes,
our weekly updates, our monthly investor
updates, and just kind of passing in
certain bits of context. And so you can
imagine doing this similarly with a file
that um
basically traverses this knowledge graph
or slices and dices by tags and things
like this. And so, um we build tools for
this. Let's see. I actually don't have
one right now.
Um but let's see if we can make one. Um
>> You want to show the full match result
TS?
>> Um yeah, so this is this is another like
SO So So the other part of this is SOPs.
So you have sort of like
markdown
as database.
And you have kind of two sections,
right? You have your front matter.
Index  deterministic.
And then you have your actual document,
which is like mostly for models.
Um
So that's
>> And And when Dash says the word front
matter, can you pull up the code really
fast, Dash? The front matter.
I want to be a little bit more explicit
about what he means by this. Front
matter is this part.
>> Is the Yeah, the So So markdown docs
support this format.
>> Yeah. And the And what you can think of
this as is we all know, if you ever have
seen cloud code, and this is just
intuitive knowledge that Dash is using
based on how he has seen cloud code
work. It might change if cloud code does
something different. But cloud code,
when it does when you first refers to a
file that's really long, it actually
just dumps out the first 100 or 100
lines or so of it. Just see what it does
approximately.
>> Yeah.
>> What that means is if you're an engineer
and you're not running docstrings at the
top of a file explaining what it does,
you're just hurting your ability for
super long files to be super useful.
Similarly, in markdown files,
can you go back?
>> Um Yep.
>> In markdown files, Dash is doing the
same thing by saying like, "Hey, if I
want to deal with a month, what is the
a num sorry a num a num The most
important thing that I have to deal with
is I really want to know like recent
information that is super super
uh important for me to know. I probably
want to have contacts and phone and
everything else on there and I probably
want to know like
any relevant files that I might want to
look into in case I I want to have like
quick jumps.
And what that does for the model is any
agent that's using this has really quick
interaction. Like, is this relevant? Is
this not relevant? And it can make a
decision for that without having to go
ahead and
actually
um
without having to go ahead and actually
like uh read the entire file. What that
means is if we go back to how context
engineering works,
the best thing you can do in forms of
context engineering, whether as a user
or as a developer, is give the answer to
the model and that's it. If you give it
the exact answer you want to put out, it
will spit it out for you.
The second best thing you can do is give
it as much data that is related to the
actual answer without having to actually
think about it.
However,
that is also really hard. So, the next
best thing you can do is give it as
little noise about what isn't relevant
so that it can actually do the right
thing. So, in this scenario, by only
pruning it to the most relevant sections
at the top, Dexter can effectively give
the model the least amount of noise, and
the noise being all the other noise on
in every single file,
without having to think about it.
So,
>> Yes.
>> There you go. We muted.
>> Um yeah, that makes a lot of sense. Um
yeah, I muted them. Uh
this is in Git Ignore, so Claude can't
find it. Um but what we have, I will
show you um
there's a couple fun things you can do.
So, like I want to talk about kind of
like deterministic context backing, and
this is like a really really
>> $2 just to run a make command?
>> Is it $2? Where does it say $2?
>> Or like at least a dollar, cuz you're
running Opus.
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. We use Opus for
everything.
Um so, yeah, this thing is going to
Okay, there's a typo.
So anyways, you can use Claude to build
out these systems and you can tell
Claude like, "Hey, I want a script."
Let's make another one.
I need a script that only fetches files
modified the last day.
Read some files for examples and put it
in a TS file I can run with fun and
tools.
So you can start to build out kind of
programmatic ways to work with this
information and then hand those tools
back to Claude. And one of the things we
do a lot is um we use slash commands to
kind of automate some of this stuff.
Um so this is like
and run the daily review SOP. So we have
um
things called SOPs and this is what I
spend most of my time doing is like,
"Okay, you're you're running a company.
What are all these things you're doing
manually?" Okay, check my email, I got
to do this. Okay, I got to go check this
thing once a week. Okay, I got to pull
these metrics. And so you can start
building these into SOPs. This is kind
of a redacted version of what we what we
use at Human Layer. So every day there's
kind of like, "Hey, you're going to
output a comprehensive markdown file."
This is actually related also to how we
do compaction. Um so I turn this on
every morning and I just brain dump into
it everything that's going on. I read my
calendar, I read a couple other things.
Um the one we use is also has a bunch of
tools to like check email and check
calendar and stuff like that which I
haven't included yet, but you can
imagine how those would fit. Um but we
say, you know, do a brain dump, um do a
metrics review. So let me see if I can
actually kick this off.
Um
See how this goes.
I haven't tested this. Um but we have
another one for our investor updates. So
I have fake investor updates for the uh
Burrito now monthly. And so, the idea
would be every day you log in or every
couple days you log in and you generate
a daily review. And then, once a month,
I just compact all the daily reviews and
then have some tools to do things like
pull metrics or pull PR links or pull
product updates from other systems and
compact them into a really nice investor
update. And you can write basically the
the SOPs become your prompts and your
commands.
Um and then they
Yeah.
>> So, one really tangible example for
everyone here is that a lot of people
are engineers. All of us probably
execute some team that does some stupid
amount of stand-up.
And most stand-ups, while stand-up is a
great ritual to actually have a forcing
function for everyone to connect, the
actual content of the update
is
um
is actually very hard.
Uh and very useless for a lot of people
to have. So, what we can do is you could
imagine running a stand-up where instead
of actually having everyone go do it,
you just look at the PRs that happened,
look at all the Git commits, expect
everyone to just like regularly be
pushing feature incomplete branches,
and just run a system that's going to
Git clone every single branch that
everyone is actively working on or
pushed in the last 2 days,
get a summary of it, get the person, get
the system, and then just write it down.
And then boom, you now have stand-up
updates for free backed by sources of
truth.
Uh and you can actually make sure your
stand-up is under 5 minutes, guaranteed.
>> Yep.
>> It's a really fancy thing that you can
do. But, this requires you, as whoever's
running this, to actually have access to
the GitHub repos and be able to write
some amount of knowledge about how uh
how it's going to work, but it doesn't
really have to be that good.
Claude, go and say you got the rest.
>> Yeah. So, usually I would come in here
and do like a big long rambling brain
dump of like, "Okay, I had these
meetings yesterday and we got these new
clients signed and I need to I need to
follow up with these six people because"
and it's like brain dump of what's on
your mind.
And then you would paste that in here.
Um
So, uh in this case, I'm not going to
send that. I'm just going to say, "Hey,
we sold a lot of burritos yesterday."
And then it's going to go through and
run through this SOP. So, it's going to
review yesterday's work, which like in
our in our in our in our repo, we have a
journal file, so the model kind of
tracks like all these different ways of
doing memory. And right now, I'm like
kind of in prototype mode. And so, we
write There's a lot of duplicated data.
And then as we refine the process and
figure out what works, we're getting
more and more concise. Like the CRM
stuff is actually pretty baked and
concise, but the some of the more like
journaling and memory and like update
stuff is still we're still figuring out
how we want that to all work.
>> Tyler asked a really interesting
question. How do you think about agents
versus workflows when automating these
non-coding tasks? I think my perspective
on all this is like I think the word
agent or workflow doesn't really matter.
What I always think about is just like
how much automation are you actually
getting and how clean is the result that
you need? If you need it to be perfect,
then like write the code. Just write the
tool that pulls the data that you want
and then have Cloud Code format into
human-readable format.
If you're okay with loosey-goosey stuff
like stand-up updates, honestly, I'll
just tell Cloud Code to get clone every
single um
get clone the repos, look at all the
branches that are modified in the last
48 hours,
give a summary of every single diff
against the main branch.
And I don't need it to be perfect and I
just I would just tell it to go do that.
I'd say, "Use sub-agents for every
single branch."
>> So, we actually do this. Um
because I'm not exactly sure what the
workflow is and I'm a little less like
concerned about like exactly what
happens here, we built this release
notes SOP as a prompt, not as a
workflow. But you could easily see how
you could be like, "Okay, fetch the last
things with an API call and then grab
the body of each one and then send that
to an LLM to format into an update um
where it's like, "Okay, use it use it
use a baml call to extract two sentences
about the release and then extract each
feature and then like the deterministic
code builds the markdown file and we may
actually do that someday but what this
becomes is a really nice way to do
prototyping. And so this thing like now
that I have this workflow I'm changing
it every day and that I can just change
the prompt and I get the results that I
want because the stuff that is like
deterministic which is like using the GH
CLI is pretty straightforward and Claude
is really good at doing these kinds of
things. If I have Claude write a tool
that check my email that's pretty easy
for it to like run and then change the
kind of like how the workflow is
supposed to work. And I'll show you
actually the trace of one of these
conversations that we had
but I use this every morning to go fetch
the PRs we merged last night and write
release notes for the latest nightly
build.
And so
we'll come back to this daily review one
but I'm going to show you the
Let's see is there release notes? I
think I archived it.
Oh here we go. This is it. So this is
our release notes from this morning. So
it ran our print context which is
showing the company identity and some of
the other examples and you know how to
get help from humans and like the people
on the team and all this stuff.
And then it does a make print index. So
this is like rather than this is the
context packing thing right? Rather than
having it go like agentically search or
use the built-in LS tool I know that
I'll get more of like context efficiency
by just having it look at every single
like markdown file. And as this gets
really really big I will probably have
it only look at recent projects and
stuff but the nice thing is is like this
becomes really easy to tune and because
it's so interactive and human in the
loop you can kind of just keep updating
it every day as you go.
>> Yeah.
>> Um but what this did was it found
it listed out the PRs and saw the merged
PRs that we had from last night. It did
the JSON body stuff. So like this is all
stuff that could be programming and
scripting, but it's all meta work. It's
all things that are like tedious back
office things that I would usually just
spend time going and compiling release
notes every day.
Um and like yes, there are tools that
will do this for you, but they're kind
of hard to customize. But, you know what
can customize text really, really well
is like a prompt in an LLM. And so, this
went through and it edited the release
and it created this um release tag for
Code Layer last night.
And here's what it looks like. So, I I I
literally did this this morning.
And then when it was done, I went and
made a video demoing it. And then it
even made me a like Slack We have a
couple like Slack channels, private
channels of like our kind of I call it
trusted testers.
Um I think some of y'all are in here.
Um but then it just made the
announcement post. So, I've given it the
format and the SOP of how to do this and
all of the steps including like hey,
when you're done, like prompt me and I
will give you a video demo. And then you
go put that in the release notes.
>> Yeah. I think the mental model that I
have found worked really well here is um
can you go back to the whiteboard?
>> Yeah.
>> This is at least the mental model that I
use. Uh where did it go?
It hid in front of you.
>> Sorry, I'm pulling it up again.
Yeah.
Um the mental model that I have found
worked really, really well I'm going to
be at the bottom decks. Is I think we're
entering like an kind of a
I think our property said this really
interestingly, which was like you have
software and then you have like software
1.0, which is like pure code.
And then you have like traditional
machine learning,
which is all about uh like writing uh
writing actual training writing training
models, collecting data, all that stuff.
And like now we have this like new box
that somehow like sits in the middle of
this stuff.
That's like
LLM stuff
is kind of what I would put it as.
And now all of a sudden a lot of the the
stuff that we used to do How do I get
rid of arrow?
I don't know how to get rid of arrow.
Okay, well, I'll figure that out later.
Um a lot of the stuff that we used to do
with uh like pure code can now just be
done by an LLM.
The only caveat is that some of the
stuff that now happens in this box is
just going to break some of the time,
but you can the trade-off is well, it
breaks all the time, it also can be a
lot more flexible and adaptable.
So, when you think about engineering, I
think people there's a discussion thread
going on about like agents versus
workflows all this other stuff.
I think the easiest way to think about
this is it's not actually about like
agents or workflows.
Agents and workflows don't really
matter. You can use agents as tools, you
can use workflows as tools. Agents can
have workflows, workflows can have
agents.
It It's really just the matter of like
whether it's a sequence of stuff or
whether you have a while loop. But, what
I find the easiest way to think about
this is
how much tolerance do I have for my
software not being 100% correct like
consistent.
Generating
Generating notes, I have a lot of
tolerance. If I make something, it's
still That's okay.
I probably trust if I add something
that's not there, also okay cuz I can go
back and edit it if it's not there.
And then it's really just a mental model
of like how much trust can I build in
the model to go and go do this. Turns
out I have a lot of trust in the model
to go and look at a bunch of Git logs
and like summarize what actually
happened based on that system.
>> Yeah.
>> Therefore, it becomes a great task
actually do LLM stuff in it.
And I think another analogy that really
breaks this down like whether or this is
like
coding or not coding, whether you're
putting in that's coding or not, is just
this analogy of like
think about how Python, you we had used
to have Python, then we had C++ then we
had C, then we used to have assembly,
and even before that we had like machine
code.
And if you go to the era in which each
of these is invented and you ask like a
C dev in like 1990s if Python is a real
language, they'd say no. You have to
know garbage collection and memory
management to be able to write code.
Turns out in 2025 that's not true. You
can write a lot of good code by just
writing Python.
And it's very possible
that the world that we live in is
whatever is going to happen here
is the same thing. You used to have to
write Python code to be able to be
called yourself an engineer and the
definition of it just changes. So, the
thing we're doing that Dex is showing
you may very well be exactly what
engineering is 5 years from now.
There's no reason that it doesn't have
to be. So, thinking of it as like kind
of almost like an extension to what
you're doing today and being like, "Oh,
for some stuff I have to write C. If I
want to invent NumPy even in Python, I
have to write C. I might even have to
write some assembly."
But for most stuff I can write Python.
Similarly, the stuff from here is for
coding tasks or non-coding tasks
you're really engineering whether you
whether you call it that today or not.
It's just what level of engineering are
you doing?
>> Yeah, and it's the conversation might
not be like, "Hey, I'm going to go write
C cuz the Python's." It's going to be
like, "Okay, cool. Like, the LLM is not
quite getting it right. I'm going to go
write Python code because I need I need
a certain level of quality or
performance or accuracy for this one
little part." And so, for that part we
drop down out of the specifications and
the words and the prompts and it's like,
"Okay, this part I'm just going to do by
hand cuz it has to be very very It's
super imp- The leverage is like super
impactful.
Um but I will say on this like workflows
versus agent stuff like what I will
probably do once I get this to a
satisfactory place, this workflow, is
I'll probably just pop open and be like,
"Great, turn this whole workflow into a
TS script and tools/releases."
Um and basically like once you figure
out like tuning exactly and you get kind
of the flow you want, you can have the
model bake it as a workflow and then it
becomes faster, more reliable, and it
just is kind of like doing the so I
mean, who knows how it's going to use
the tools to do the summary? Like I
probably have to prompt it to say like,
"Okay, use my Anthropic API key and call
Anthropic for these phases."
Um but in general, if you can figure out
the workflow and then you can pinpoint
which parts of this are AI-driven, then
you can make the deterministic parts
deterministic, faster, don't spend
tokens on them, don't wait for the model
to figure it out because it's the same
every single time.
>> Can I show something related to that,
Dexter?
>> yeah. Go for it.
>> Okay.
So, this is again inspired heavily by
what Dexter does. Let me just make sure
that I'm
Okay, I'll share my Obsidian cuz I can
do that the safely. Um I wasn't sure
what's on my desktop right now. So, I
was like, "Let me Let me make sure it's
safe." Um
Um so, when you think about this stuff,
for example, like one of the things that
we do is we think really hard about
We've been doing a new thing where we
write design docs heavily using Claude,
inspired by this thing.
>> your Obsidian thing?
>> Yeah. Um
>> I've been waiting to see this. This is
like, okay.
>> So, we write all our design docs now
through Claude.
And it's very useful. And for example,
one of the stuff that we're
investigating right now is
how is um actually this is a bad design
doc cuz this is going to have too much
context for people. But I will talk
about this.
Cool. So, one of the things that we'd
love to add into BAML is discriminated
unions. I would love for people to be
able to write things like this so then
they can actually get like really
beautiful TypeScript classes that look
like this automatically
that actually have state and stuff
attached to them. It's really hard to do
naming
for some reason.
But part of doing this discriminated
union stuff is sometimes at the top of
every doc, I want it to go ahead and
have like links to files and everything.
And this is super abstract so I don't
actually restrict it too much.
But a lot more of the design docs I have
I have a new prompt actually that I'm
using. I actually want a summary
of everything in here so I can quickly
find stuff about like what branch was I
working on, what was the date on this,
who's the person that worked on this?
And I don't do something very smart
here. This is actually seven different
API calls to Claude code cuz it runs
like seven different commands to go
assemble this.
What I should be doing is I should have
a script.
>> Make a script that gets the metadata.
Yeah, we did that. So we used to have it
be four calls to Claude code and then
we're like, "Okay, this is the same
every time." And actually like the way
that the bash works is that you have to
pull in like you can't white list it in
permissions because of how the high
queue call evaluates your allowed
policy. And so we were just like, "Okay,
cool. We'll make a script and we'll
allow this the script."
>> Exactly. And by doing this, you can one,
not only have your agents work faster
cuz now instead of waiting for four
calls to get this happen before all this
dumps out.
You used to one call.
Um and it just pulls out all the data
and go dumps it out immediately to the
file.
So one, you get expediency. One, you
save a lot of money cuz remember the way
that these the way that you get charged
for all this stuff is by
your context window. And if you're
running four scripts with the same
context window before writing the final
document, one, two, three, four, your
context window is being built to you
four times to collect this data.
So if you spend Well, part of it is
cached, but
it's still being built to you four times
to build this data. Um and the way
Claude code does the caching from what I
understand is Claude has at most four
caching segments built in.
So at best you're getting a 4x uh
reduction on parts of the window, but
for really really large segments, you're
not getting that much.
>> And you're you're still always paying
for the generation, right? The model has
to say bash this, bash that, bash this
thing over here. And so each one of
those you're still paying for output
tokens.
>> Exactly. And this was if you go back and
look at the Sorry. If you go back and
look at the Now I'm going to throw out a
different thing. Sweet agent tool chain,
one of the best innovations they had was
instead of giving the model super
high-level tools like just bash. So for
example, we could take Claude code's
only tool is just bash.
And it can do everything through your
Problem is the model just works better
if it can just run like read file
instead of having to write the bash
command for reading a file,
read file with this line number instead
of having to go write the bash command
for reading this file with the line
number or range.
It just like reduces the amount of
effort the model has to do and it can
think at a higher level. And it's kind
of like how when you do a design doc, if
in the process of writing this design
doc, I have to be like, here's the exact
implementation of this at the same time
of designing the system,
my brain can't operate in that way. So,
it's really useful for me to actually
just write the design doc like, what is
the end user going to see? What is the
end user going to interface with? And
only after that,
go forward and then
work on the implementation plan in some
way or another.
But it's
the idea is you can break down the
problem and similarly when you go do
non-coding tasks, you want to think
about it in the same way.
What are the systems of the prompt that
I can do in the very beginning that are
super, super verbose and repetitive and
perhaps have some ambiguity to them?
And then eventually, I can apply an
optimization function like if you were
to optimize code, you'd make it faster
and more reliable.
Same thing. I can say, "Hey, I'm doing
the same thing four times. This thing is
very deterministic. Let's move to
software 1.0 and write regular code to
go solve this problem."
And the rest of my system will still be
software 3.0 which is more about LLM
driven
software.
>> Super dope. Um
should we see if our script I have a
couple other things I can show off, but
any questions so far? I really like
Kyle's point on like Master has a good
take on this. Agents and workflows need
to be composable, right? A workflow can
call agents, agents can call workflows.
They're just kind of these different
building blocks that can have like
infinite depth if you want them to
depending on the complexity of your
problem.
>> Um John asked the question of like has
this been able to keep the code base
consistent, coherent, and um coherent
and consistent?
Um
I will not share with you what I said.
I'll actually share with you what one of
my engineers said because obviously I'm
going to be biased in many different
ways. Um
So, I will share with you general
And then that's going to And this
technique, by the way, really, really
inspired by
actually I just showed you the DM.
Um
So, firstly, first thing while he's been
doing this is Claude code doesn't read
really large files. We have some really,
really large files in our code base.
His response
immediately
we need to optimize for this.
So, he's like we should not have large
files anymore. So, we'll probably add a
linting rule in our code base to go
solve this.
Um
Like it's just that good. And our code
base is complex. We're building a
compiler in Rust. It's not the easiest
task for a language to go do.
Um the model is really surprised at the
fact that it works, but the most
important part is actually
I don't know if it's in here. We're
discussing this for a while. The hardest
part that actually turns out to be is
80% of it is just using it efficiently.
The whole planning phase that we do, the
research phase, that was heavily,
heavily inspired by Dexter. I would have
never thought about it. I didn't believe
in Claude code to that degree. Like it
works, but I didn't think it could do
hard things.
>> We just merged the PR today. Last
Saturday, me and Vibhav sat down and I
was trying to teach him this stuff and I
was like, "Here's the prompts. Go try
them for a thing." And after about 45
minutes, I think Vibhav said, "I don't
know if this is going to work for our
code base. Like I already knew where
this was. This would have taken me 15
minutes. Like I don't think this is for
us."
And I said, "Okay, what do you want to
do?" He's like, "Dex, how about you
drive?" And And I was like, "Cool, I'll
drive, but I want you to pick a really
big, complex thing that we're going to
work on cuz I want to prove to you that
this works in big code bases." And we
sat there for 7 hours
and we coded two features. We added WASM
support to BAML. So, now you can run it
in the browser.
>> Be very transparent. That one is not
merged yet.
>> I know. Well, yeah, neither of them got
merged that day.
>> No. The abort one
>> The abortion one, the the abort
controller one, uh adding cancellation
to BAML got merged.
Um which is like I think it was what,
like 35,000 lines of code? And a lot of
it was generated, but it was like a a
crap ton of code that we wrote.
>> Yeah. Um to give you context here, this
whole process that we built, this
problem was a very, very hard problem.
We've had three people on our team
trying to attempt it. They've spent four
days each individually at different time
periods of the BAML project.
No one merged it. And there's reasons
why it didn't merge or no one was able
to solve it.
But, what's interesting is that this
technique allowed us to go and build
this out and get it working demo in
about 7 hours while in parallel doing
some other really hard thing, which is
web assembly support.
And then we were actually able to go
ahead and actually build playground
support in our VS Code extension that
actually allows you to cancel something
while running. So, not only did we add
it to the core runtime, so you as a
TypeScript dev can just like abort a
method that's running under the hood,
but you can also cancel it in web
assembly.
And this project would have just never
happened
uh if it wasn't for Viper coding. So, it
does work. That said,
while it did produce almost the right
code, it didn't produce what we call
like clean code.
So, while once we got it working, we had
to go do something, which is we had to
go ahead and issue some sort of react um
uh some sort of
um
cleaning, I would say, along the hood,
where we had to go and say like, "Hey,
here you created some methods that don't
need to exist. Use the existing methods
instead."
And don't extend the API interface. But,
that was much, much easier to do
once we had a working example and it
worked end-to-end and it actually had
unit tests and testability to just
change the internal mechanisms to be
more along the design we had.
It's definitely 80% less work than it
would have been otherwise. Like no doubt
in my mind.
>> Anyways, we're not here to talk about
Claude for coding, but that was a great
like little side tangent.
Um
What else do you think would be useful
to talk about? I mean, I have more demos
we can look at this daily review thing
and see if it's running. So, it's like
running our pull metrics script, which
>> Yeah.
>> is a thing.
>> is running, I'll take a couple more
questions. Someone Slava asked like, why
not use a local database? I see one set
of MD files. Well, Slava, the question
is really just the same thing that we've
talked about the whole time, which is
it's an optimization spectrum.
The V0, the most lossy form of this
data, is a markdown file. If you find
that, hey, we are scaling to thousands
of people, you can optimize it to use a
SQL database over time. But, the whole
point of this is you don't have to on
day one.
Uh
is it running yet, Dex?
>> Yeah, so these are some of our tools.
So, I showed the like make print context
command, which shows, you know, the
company overview, the recent investor
updates. This is how you can kind of
deterministically pack your context
without Claude needing to go to Again,
the same thing that you mentioned about
like, hey, rather than like doing this,
we just do it all as a script. Same
idea. It's like if I know that every
time this thing runs, I want it to have
all this context, and I don't want to
put it all in Claude.md for whatever
reason, because sometimes I might not.
But, it's like 90% of workflows I'm
going to tell it to call the like make
print context print index things. And
then we actually use something called
like ctx.md,
which is like run make print context
make run make print index
follow the user's ask.
And so, now I can say,
um
/ctx
what's the last investor update? And it
will get all this context automatically
without having to go read a bunch of
files. So if there's stuff you always
want to know and this gets back into
context engineering, right? Because if
you just put everything in, then you
were going to take up too much of the
context window and you're going to
distract it and there's going to be
flows and things like this. But this is
kind of a hopefully this technique is
clear of how you could basically give
the model access to or you can kind of
like streamline your workflows and just
kind of guarantee that the model will
always
have kind of the core base context. And
the reason why we don't use Claude MD
for this is because what we talked about
2 weeks ago is if you look in the Claude
code system prompt, it does inject
Claude MD, but it says a system
instruction at the end because most
people don't know how to write a good
Claude MD because they're not context
engineers. They or they're they're
they're aspiring context engineers. They
got to they got to figure figure out
like learn this stuff is it says this
may not be relevant. Only consider this
advice if it's highly relevant to what
you're working on. And so if you want to
guarantee stuff ends up in the context
window in a way that is sort of
will get more attention from the model,
then you can be a little bit more
deterministic about how this works.
>> Yeah. And I think you asked interesting
question of like how do you deal with it
if you have a long-running task that
Claude needs to go run
and you want to take a dependency on it
in a future task. Well, this really goes
back to like you as a user need to
understand the restrictions of the agent
that you are using.
Claude code doesn't really have a way to
add dependencies on background tasks.
There's nothing you as a user can do
to really make that work super super
reliably. Claude code lets you run a
background task but it doesn't let you
depend on that background task for some
other task.
So until the agent builder enables that
capability, you can't do it.
So
sadly, that's just like understanding
what the limits and stuff are. And if
you really need that because your
workflow is constantly like that, well
then
you'll have to build your own agent
loop. And that actually builds that in
as a mechanism for what the system does.
And the reason for that is because if
you're running a background task and you
want to put the pency on it, then
whatever system task you're using has to
have context on here's all the
background task that I'm currently
running.
And therefore, here's how you go build
this out.
Under the hood.
>> Um, lot of questions about the Claude
code system prompt. We did uh, I think
we dropped a snippet of it in the last
AI that works.
Or the one where we talked about Claude.
Oh, not that.
Let's just have a look at the whole
repo. So,
context engineering for coding agents, I
believe it was.
Eh, no, that's context engineering.
There is
>> Um, you can definitely see the system
prompt of Claude code because under the
hood it's just making a network call.
Uh, and you can just like proxy it and
then you can see the prompt.
>> Um,
>> You have it somewhere right here.
>> Yeah, here's the trace. So, this is you
can literally just point Claude at a
proxy and have it log everything out and
then send this the the the request
upstream to Anthropic. This is what a
lot of people doing. But like, yeah,
here's our user message.
As you answer the user's questions, you
can kind of see all of this and it says
Here it is. Important, this context may
or may not be relevant to your task. You
should not respond to this context or
otherwise consider it in your response
unless it is highly relevant to your
task. So, every time you put something
in Claude MD, it gets suffixed with
this. Most of the time it is not
relevant.
>> So, that means if you are trying to tell
it to do something in Claude MD, like
this is really important,
and
it my model might decide that it's not
important because this is just part of
the context window that the Claude agent
does no matter what you do. And there's
nothing you can do to edit this except
have a proxy and remove that manually
from the prompt in your proxy layer.
>> And this is the engineering part, right?
This is about if you don't know exactly
what's put in, if you don't know the
tool descriptions, if you don't know
kind of how Claude is being talked So,
here's the raw body, but we can actually
go get the JSON.
Um so, here's yeah, here's the system
message. Here's the
um
Here's the tool. So, here's the task
tool. People talk about sub-agents.
Here's the prompt for the sub-agent.
Launch a new agent that has access to
all the tools when you're searching for
a keyword that you're not confident. So,
this is like understanding how this the
tool the task tool is exposed to Claude
is really important for when you're
prompting it. And so, I don't say launch
a sub-agent, I say launch a task because
that's more likely to have the right
effect. And when I tell it to launch a
task, I tell it to put in the dis- in
the prompt how to prompt the agent
because I want to get more clear
specific things out of that sub-agent.
I don't know if that answers the
question.
>> No, I think that does that.
Um Richard asked a really interesting
question about hey, makes me think that
an IDE had a window for
deterministically managing context
windows, that'd be super useful.
I think today that would probably be
true. I think tomorrow it won't matter.
And the same realization I think is with
Python. I think a lot of people used to
say that in Python if you if you're not
garbage collecting automatically or at
the right time and you can't manually
control it, you can't write good code.
Doesn't matter today.
And I think as the models get better,
like deterministically managing every
single word matters less and less. If
you're using a 1B model, it does matter.
You do really need to manage every
single word that goes in.
But if you're not, it honestly, if
you're using the latest models today,
I suspect what you need as a user need
to do is just like manage the sections
of context, not necessarily every single
word to that degree.
Um and there's probably some usefulness
because even as an agent developer,
like
I would have never I have never actually
read the research and um
I've never actually read the research
prompts that Dasha gave me. I've never
read the create plan prompts that Dasha
gave me. I've never read the ones it
gave me. And they work. And the whole
point here is that if they didn't work,
I would go read the prompt.
And you can think of it like how you
would debug as an engineer.
Like if something works, you don't
really care what the API does under the
hood. You don't care how much of a black
box it is. Same with context
engineering. Thing is working, don't
bother understanding it. The model's
good enough, it's working. The minute it
stops working, go figure out why.
>> Yeah, I've never read the source code of
the cat command and I have no no reason
to or desire to, cuz the API is clean
and it always does what it says.
>> Exactly.
And I think that's really what context
engineering is about is like you don't
you can when we did the performance
engineering for last 10 years, whenever
I did that,
every line of code that you write, I
promise you there's some way to make it
faster. Almost definitely. There's
something you can do to make it faster.
You don't need to.
The value of performance engineering is
not about making every line of code
faster. It's actually about knowing what
lines of code to spend your effort on,
so you can make that part of the system
faster. Same with context engineering.
Don't make every single system perfectly
engineered. Focus on the parts of the
system that actually need to be
perfectly engineered. So in this
workflow that we did today,
Dasha really didn't have to optimize a
lot of this stuff.
Because
like it works. It does the thing it
wants. Doesn't matter how expensive it
is. And most of the stuff that he's
doing is
allowed to be lossy.
>> It's allowed to be lossy and it's the
kind of thing that like without a lot of
prompting, the model can still get it
right.
>> Yeah, or at least 85% right. And for the
task that you're doing, it doesn't
matter if it's 100% right. It just needs
to be
directionally correct. Like change logs
or contact conversations. Like here's
the last thing you talked about, and bye
bye.
Like none of that stuff needs to be
perfect or capture every single word of
it.
>> Yeah. And and the the reason why it
doesn't have to be perfect is like when
I build this stuff, I work backwards
from the workflows, which is like what's
the end goal is like I want to send my
team an update every week. I want to
send my investors an update every month.
I want to send a public update to our
mailing list every month. And I want to
send our like trusted testers good
release notes that are high signal and
high quality every morning. Um or every
couple days. But mostly every morning
cuz we're shipping too much to do two
releases in a day.
>> Yeah.
Um
we'll take a couple questions and then
I've got a flight to Amsterdam. So we're
going to we're going to probably cut it
a little bit shorter than normal. If you
guys haven't seen the Code Lair tool, um
that sure will drop a link.
It is the coolest thing that I have used
for paralyzing how much code I can get
done
at any given time. I have I consider
myself a pretty good engineer, but I
realized that I was a novice before I
used this thing and now I use it and I'm
so much better than I used to be. And I
think I aspire to be as good as Dexter.
Uh
>> Thanks, buddy.
>> Uh check it out. If you're not using it,
uh definitely check it out. Give Dexter
some feedback.
>> Yep. There's a wait list there. I just
put the link in. We'll put it in the
show notes. Um
uh you can go find it on GitHub and use
the brew install command. I am asking
early users to jump on the wait list so
that I can watch you use it for the
first time and get your feedback and get
you added to some of our like private
testing channels.
That'll probably be true for another
couple weeks as we iron out the last of
the stability things and really pull in
user feedback. So yes, technically you
can go find it, but I would prefer to
onboard you uh directly. And so we're
going to start letting people in off the
wait list pretty soon. Uh so uh I can't
stop you cuz it's free and open source
forever and you can just go find the
release, but if you want to help out,
you can join the wait list and you can
get added to the group DMs with Vybhav
and some of the cool people who are
early testers.
>> And definitely just like if you really
want to skip the list, just like add us
a DM on Discord or something and you'll
get through much faster.
Um and that'll be the easiest way.
>> Cool. Questions?
>> Would be
That's would have same sense of
>> Any other questions right now, everyone?
Uh it sounds like
not too many.
>> Uh do you think the domain of tasks that
can be achieved with this approach is
going to keep growing? Will we hit some
point where humans don't even determine
the SOPs and communication strategies?
>> Um
My opinion is honestly, I think it's
like software. Yes, like yes.
Inevitably so. And not just because the
models will get better. I think even if
the models don't get better, like the
agentic loops that we write write you
that we use to leverage the models will
get better and the tooling around them
will get better. So like it's an
inevitability. Like even if Python
doesn't like change fundamentally
architecturally,
the libraries people build make it more
usable every week, every day.
Um when we built Bammel like part of
Bammel on day one was definitely worse,
but like we just add more stuff into it
so people can build more complicated
things. Like that's just the way
software works. So anything that is pure
bits on a machine, generally bits moving
around on a machine generally gets
better over time and the capabilities
over time. As long as people give great
feedback
and leverage it further.
>> Uh Richard, great question. Is project
management software going away? Project
management software is the only SaaS we
still use every day. Um that's funny.
That and Superhuman. Uh so it's things
like GitHub and Linear we still use
because it provides a nice collaboration
space and shared artifacts. It's a
little bit harder to do with just like
markdown files in GitHub when you want
to have lots of comments and multiplayer
and attach assets and things like that.
Although Vibhav, I don't know, I have to
try your Obsidian workflow cuz if you
could create a shared Obsidian space,
maybe you can just drop everything in
markdown and it's not that much more
efficient than having the model fetch
the stuff, but like
I don't like the linear MCP because it
dumps a bunch of JSON into my context
window. So we wrote a script that wraps
it and pulls all the comments in one go.
>> Yeah, exactly. And that's again because
the linear team doesn't understand
context engineering, so they're doing
dumb things with it. And they're just
giving you stuff in a way that doesn't
make sense that you know how to do
better.
So you're like, I can get way better
juice if I don't use it directly.
Um I also agree with like I think people
always are like, "Ah, cloud code is
going to do everything." I actually
think that's wrong. Um I think the best
way to think about it is like we don't
have one website to rule them all.
We have a ton of different websites that
we all go to that do slightly different
things.
Uh and I don't see that ever really
changing. We'll have different tools
that we use all the time.
Uh
tools are just a natural way of humans
interfacing data and people have
different patterns and different UIs
that they like.
Um
Yeah, Dexter's comment about what
strategies you use to keep keep context
from getting uh too big.
Always be compacting. Whether you're
using  compact in cloud code,
whether you're using manual compactions
like what Dexter and I do with research
and planning, the idea is you want to
have some sort of state system that
isn't the chat log itself.
And you want to be able to review that,
read that, understand that, which is why
I personally have found Dexter's way of
having a file as a source of truth that
I can just go read at any point to be
extremely powerful because whenever the
agent does steer off, I can restart the
context, feed in that file, and then
boom, I'm done.
>> Yeah, I actually almost wrote always be
clearing because clear is actually what
we use. We don't use the
compact. So when I say compact, it's
little C compact, which is like find
your own way to squeeze down the context
into the things that are important to
you. Not And whether the cloud way works
well for you, that's great, but what we
have is kind of custom prompts that are
like, "Cool, make a list of every file
you touched and snippets of all the
changes you made and what you were
working on and what's currently broken
and what are the next steps." And that
works. Having that write that to a
markdown file, then you can edit it, you
can see it, you can control it, you can
learn how to get better at that
prompting.
Um is a really powerful skill and is
again, it's all about context
engineering. How do you take a bunch of
information and distill it down into
fewer tokens that are just as valuable
to the model.
>> Um you asked a question, what do you
think about the role of MCP over time? I
think we just stated it with Dexter
being like the linear MCP does a dumb
thing, so I just wrapped it and actually
made it do the right thing. MCPs are
just API calls.
If the API caller knows what they're
doing, it's a
API calls are good to use.
If you're using it as a dumping ground
to just have it do a lot of things, your
agent probably won't work cuz 90% of the
tools that people build probably are
built incorrectly because most people
are not on the bleeding edge of actually
thinking about context engineering. And
if you are,
you're being held back. It's just where
you think the median is versus where you
are.
And the median right now is pretty bad.
>> Aw.
>> Um
>> Let's make it better. I mean, that's why
we're here, right?
>> why we're here. Yeah, we want to lift it
up.
>> John says, "This is the kind of stuff
people will sell courses on in 18
months. We should get a CC by and A so
that people can't sell our shit."
>> That's right. I don't really care. I
think the best kind of education is
given out for free and that's what all
good content is.
Um why not take over the user's content
completely by dynamically generating
them before each agent
um execution?
I think that's a thing that you can do,
Slava, but really it goes down to again
the same point, which is
if you're going to go ahead and take
over the user's context completely, you
better hope that your users are real
novices cuz they're advanced users, they
will not be okay with that. They'll be
like, "Dexter, I'm like, this thing
isn't working cuz I'm trying to have it
something do something much more
complicated than what you planned to to
have it do."
>> This is something else I'm saying. This
is show me the prompt.
>> Exactly. It says it's show me the
prompt. And the whole point is like by
taking over the user's context
completely, while you do lift the floor
a little bit,
the thing that you don't do is you
actually bring down the ceiling a lot.
>> Yep.
>> So, it's a trade-off of what you're able
to go build. And if you're okay bringing
out the ceiling cuz the usability of
what people want is very low, it's okay.
That's what that's totally useful.
Generating release notes seems like one
of those things where you can bring down
the ceiling a lot and just make your
users' life a lot better by bringing
down the floor bringing up the floor.
But, if it's something like generating
arbitrary code in cloud code, you
probably don't want that. And cloud code
works best because Dexter can put in
whatever he wants into the context and
know what have it do roughly the right
thing.
>> Dex.
>> Um let's take one or two more questions.
Um are those here I mean that Yeah,
we'll push the code out soon. I think we
should Do you want to push the research
and prompts out, too? Or we can do that
in a different episode, actually. We
should do that later. I think that's
>> Yeah, no. I mean, we should do another
episode where you walk through your
Obsidian flow. Like really in practice,
how does it work? How do people interact
with it? What's your workflow? Um I
think that'd be really interesting. Um
>> Yeah, we'll share the prompts out then
once we tune them a little bit. Um and
then let's just see if there's any more
questions.
Um Kyle, the GraphQL will never be the
answer. It never was. It never will be.
Um good try, though. Um
and I think um
I think that is it from questions.
>> Excellent.
>> Um all right. Thank you everyone for
joining. Um we'll see you again next
week. I will be in the middle of the day
at Germany time, so we'll see how well
that goes. Uh but uh we'll have a fun
time and we'll get a couple more bits of
episode out and content out.
>> Awesome. All right. Bye-bye, everyone.
>> Always good seeing you, Dex. All right.
>> all later.